we had no sip i expected way more from
the oldest
bachelorette we had the cockdale
party why are you so perfect i'm not
perfect i feel like you're so perfect
and we had the shortest season ever this
might be the shortest season ever
this is your the bachelor season 16
episode three recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
anybody else have anything they want to
share hi everybody
it's me lauren zima and i'm not
screaming because it's halloween week a
no no no
i'm screaming because what an episode of
the bachelorette
what did you think of this phenomenal
episode
what a time we are having aren't we and
by we i mean us
and also the multiple men but only one
who matters and also the multiple
bachelorettes
right right yes we got our first
official confirmation that the tasha
train is pulling
into the station we are gonna talk about
it all
let's get to it
oh that's nice okay but before we can
get to a woman we love
we have to discuss a man we no longer
want to think of
i'm calling him joseph no no no no
no no stop yes yes yes everybody we want
to say no no no
to yosef take that y out of your name
guy you deserve an
n right there joseph starts the episode
off by
[ __ ] pissing me off okay flames
on the side of my face breathing
breath heaving breath i was
absolutely appalled joseph is talking
about the dodge ball date and
he says that if he was on that date he
would not participate
in the strip dodgeball element if i had
been on that date
i sure as hell wouldn't have crossed
that line totally fine cool i get it
um then he says that claire as the
oldest bachelorette
is supposed to be the most mature i
expected a lot more from the oldest
bachelorette that's ever been
joseph age does not equal maturity
and no no no a dodo don't i think that
life experiences
and what you learn from those
experiences equals maturity
we got a lot of really immature like 55
year olds bopping around la you know i'm
gonna tell you that right off the bat
okay
so yeah joseph is trying to play it like
he's going to speak to claire
and air some things out but my second
issue with what he does
is that it's not just about what you're
saying it's about how you're saying it
you know what i'm saying because don't
drink for every totally
over-the-top word choice he made it's so
humiliating
and degrading so appalled a completely
classless display
and then don't drink for the
over-the-top tone in which he said them
you're completely classless claire i
mean
i mean i mean the man is talking about
how he sacrificed time with his daughter
to be here
i've sacrificed a lot to be here and i
get it
yeah and claire gets it she says
look my mom is dying and i'm here
honestly i get it my mom is
dying yeah and this
cuts her off it continues
don't drink for every incredibly
unnecessarily insulting thing he says to
claire
he says you're not setting the right
example for my daughter
you're not setting the right example for
my daughter
i am ashamed to be associated with you
i'm ashamed to be associated
with you and when claire says i've
listened to you for the last 20 minutes
he says i'm not done yet
i've listened to you for the last 20
minutes and i'm not done yet
and i want to give a cheers to claire
see for claire c for calm we see her
being calm
through all this listening
to all this and then she shut
him down get him out of here claire you
know what
you are done and he
says remember
you're almost 40.
remember you're almost 40. take your ass
home bro
i made my point earlier so unlike yosef
i will use my own words wisely and
conserve them now listen to me claire
listen hey
never in a million years did i ever
think i would have to
utter these words again claire has to
pull one out of her arsenal she's got to
bring one out of the lore
she's gotta find one from the history
books
and tells joseph she never thought she'd
have to say this again
but i would never want my children
having a father like you okay
i would never want my children having a
father like you get out of here claire
oh you did not settle claire cause i
didn't settle for men
like that and we do raise our glass
to not settle it what did you all think
of the way that claire handled this
whole
exchange with joseph get out of here
claire we went from a
horror film to a fairy dale
are you okay yes dale is here and this
is a critical moment everybody like
you're dealing with a lot
but focus on what matters and who
matters okay claire has said over and
over again
she's kind of exhausted of being on her
own she had to deal with losing her dad
her mom is ill she's been quarantining
alone
lots of other things she wants to be
protected and taken care of and to have
a partner who will come over and protect
me
and make sure i'm okay and not have to
go through it alone
and dale's doing that i think when it
comes to what's gonna happen next
these are all tell dale signs like
telltale but also like
claire wants to tell dale she loves him
okay
so claire's been through too much and
she's ending the cocktail party
don't think i can go on with the night
and i'm not up for
conversations right now and i hope you
guys understand and i felt that that was
fair and the guys were bummed but
they got it too and i just want to give
some shout outs to
bennett this episode because man oh man
am i loving him
i don't feel he's getting his due what
do you guys think i really hope to see
him on paradise or something
he's just there serving you know kind of
a supportive frown
do we love bennett let me know in the
comments below we go right to the rose
ceremony and
don't drink for every guy whose name you
don't know and honestly for every guy
you don't know if you've ever seen
brandon jordan
jay
who are you
dale but again bennett is there with a
comforting deep breath
please don't send bennett home bennett
[Music]
bennett will you accept this rose of
course
first date card right here then the
first group date card comes
and uh this guy who i also don't know i
think he's named ed
he reads it i just need a moment
for what might be the most lackluster
reading
of the names ever on this show jason
jay easy jason blake ed
reilly dale the tepid applause that he
gets in response
is warrenton
before the group date claire is
journaling and by journaling i mean
writing down her and dale's names
together dale plus claire dale plus
claire
dale dale dale dale
dale plus claire dale plus claire
dale dale dale dale
oh and diana is here a former
bachelorette here to discuss with claire
the journey that she's on with all these
men name's dale
dale dale his name is dave looking out
for dale look out for dale
oh wow wow oh dear dear dear
claire has a pair of dale's pants
these are dale's pants in her
room what
claire has dale's pants and it gets even
uh weirder to be honest from there she's
smelling them
i mean they smell like it let me think
and then diana smells them
aren't they used what 46. oh my god
what does that even mean i don't wear
band sizes diana you didn't come all the
way here and
quarantine and covet test to smell these
dirty pants
no so what comes out of this discussion
other than a questionably hygienic
moment something big
claire says and i quote this might be
the shortest season ever this might be
the shortest season ever
[Laughter]
and oh my gosh i forgot these guys are
waiting for the group date
yes they've been waiting uh the guy who
was talking slowly earlier
is unconscious now he put himself to
sleep
hello but claire finally comes in
to the group date and sits of course
right next to dale
it's the group dale and
what she said to the group did not make
sense to me we
originally had a day date planned but
obviously it's getting late did it make
sense to you
listen i'm not good at math it's not my
strong suit but
this addition and subtraction feels wild
claire says that they
had a day date a day-date plan and a
cocktail party
to have a really long cocktail party
tonight but now
there's no day date so and they're just
gonna do a cocktail party
essentially i scratch the daytime date
because that means more
quality time because to me what matters
is the quality time
[Music]
two minus one is one
that's one plus two plus one plus one i
also don't know why these guys wouldn't
have gotten
a sooner heads up that the day-date just
wasn't happening at all
a claire comes in tells them it's not
happening shocker we know
we're not on it all i thought to myself
was something went wrong here
it just felt strange felt weird didn't
feel right
[Music]
kind of like sniffing those pants and i
was like
but you know we're still having fun it's
a great episode so don't drink for every
time
someone said time when i get quality
time with her
time is everything here time to have
some time
cheers to spending quality time together
for that matter what the hell don't
drink every time someone said dale this
episode
dale's alright dale i mean dale
dale came back smiling with dale you
know he wasted a lot of guys time
tonight
literally all i've ever wanted is a man
like dale
dale it's everything that
i'm looking for i'm so falling in love
with dale
dale you had another good night with
dale here dale
dale dale plus claire dale plus claire
dale dale dale
dell dale dale his name is dave looking
out for dale look out for dale
dale dale's in here
[Music]
it's the cocktail party and we're
finally getting time
well dale is yeah let's call it the
cockdale party why don't we
dale asks for the first few minutes with
claire if
i can speak with claire first even if
it's for five minutes i would greatly
appreciate that
and those first few minutes involve
going to claire's hotel room
casa de la claire oh okay and i
say great get involved this is my
dining room okay let's drink to it
telling each other they're perfect
what's up why are you so perfect
i'm not perfect i feel like you're so
perfect perfect
making out with each other what's up
i'm so happy does dale know his pants
are in here
what's up
and oh they are really making out now
and yes this camera work and oh this
leg work oh we all know that dale's
pants are there now yes that's a shot
those are his pants a different pair but
his pants so we learned that what dale
said would be five minutes
was really an hour they've been gone for
an hour
but we learn it from easy who has an
uneasy
experience when he discovers where
claire and dale
have been and easy is defining
third wheel yeah so this is awkward
so easy is trying to ease into uh
claire's room
oh is there a knock on the door oh let
me go hide in the closet
and things get difficult um claire
doesn't want dale to leave
she's like where's my kiss
don't okay you can kiss me don't drink
during all this
awkward welcome to my house yeah
dale's in here yeah so this is awkward
having a conversation about christmas
[ __ ] okay
hold on we huge
can i have some of these snacks those
are dog snacks
claire finally brings easy in and what a
tone to this whole moment
it felt like she was selling him a couch
or something you know like he'd come
into her furniture store
cool come on in and have a seat yeah
come on in so
this is gonna be our new chase and it's
got a beautiful plush to it a fabulous
feel a really velvety texture
it's comfortable yet sturdy and the
quality is unparalleled
this one's going to last thank you for
uh inviting me to your house can i send
you
yeah thank you for coming to my house
thanks for coming
but as kind as claire is being to easy's
face uh we break the fourth wall a
little bit and
hear claire clearly talking to a
producer
i love when we break the fourth wall
claire says to this producer and i quote
can we hurry the rest along
can we like kind of hurry
the rest is everybody but dale yes
there's the best
and the rest so i think we know the
quality time
that claire cares about is time with
dale
what time is it dale central standard
dale o'clock it's daylight savings time
and
dale comes back
oh after all that i mean the other guys
had gotten mad at him because dale had
been trying to make toast the whole
episode trying to do group hugs
and he comes back a second time claire's
like
where you been what have you been up to
uh just waiting to see you again where
do you think he was claire the [ __ ]
desert
the dale cert oh how many dale puns can
we make
tattledale cockdale fairydale dalespin
dale gates claire had all those puns
give some to dale
[Music]
excuse me guys honestly you guys at this
point
everybody feels like a third wheel to
claire and dale i mean we might be a
third wheel
ask the audience are we
the third wheel
let me know in the comments below
but i love it i'll be the third wheel
third fourth fifth twelfth i don't care
it's an amazing season
there's a rose on the table there is i
don't wanna
shock anybody but dale gets the roast
dale will you accept this rose
yes all right i'm gonna go to bed have a
good night you guys
then claire's like okay dale here you go
here's the rose everybody else i'm going
to bed good night
uh but claire is still in the process
and she goes on this one-on-one with
zach yeah so um
um but today we're going to date
you ready absolutely do want to continue
giving the quick shout outs to bennett
though uh
he is standing behind this lamp and he's
just glowing
[Music]
whew player does say how good dale looks
looking at dale's face god he looks so
hot in his hat today
so that's nice for zach and she says
that she was ready to
game on with dale in the bedroom i was
ready to
game on in the bedroom with dale last
night it was hard to hold back
so that's nice for zach and uh zach
has a nervous energy apparently and
claire says it was stressing her out
and she just wishes dale was there
that excited energy has channeled into
nervous energy
and it stresses me the heck out it's
just like
in moments like this i wish dale was
here what did you guys
think of that the thing is dale seems to
be the gold standard for claire at this
point
she's just comparing everyone to him
things do get weird
claire leans in for a kiss and zach
seems to be leaning in as well but
claire thinks he's rejecting her what
oh and then things take
a turn zach is grabbing claire's neck in
in a way that i guess would best be
described as uncomfortable i i don't get
this sense from what he's saying that he
means it maliciously or in a scary way
but
it doesn't look great no why did you
stop what are you doing
i was right there wait hold on why'd you
stop
what did you guys think of this moment
uh claire kind of shuts down and she
explains that it's because of her past
trauma i might be a little extra
sensitive about it because i have done
all the work
these last few years on healing my
traumas i understand that
the way zach grabbed claire was too much
it was what did you guys think let me
know in the comments below
claire ends up not showing up for the
dinner with zach instead chris harrison
does and he tells
zach he's been sent home claire's not
coming to dinner unfortunately
that means you're going to be going home
and time for another group
date oh this one is without dale but it
is with bennett
and he's holding the door open for
everyone oh and we are going to do
a rose to help you guys roast each other
it's one big roast fest you guys what do
you all think of a roast i don't love a
roast
i don't think they're ever that funny
and it's just a little awkward and mean
but that is a good trope for a bachelor
date
great emmy nominated queen of comedy oh
and comedy queen margaret
show is here how fabulous she
quarantined for the show we have to
champion all the celebrities who do show
up this season i think they're gonna be
few and far between but we know they
quarantined
to get here cheers to that and the
audience is gonna be
the rest of the guys from the house oh
but dale is here yes the other guys are
in the audience
and what did you surmise as the
motivation
for that here part of me wants to say
the producers were stirring things up
as they should but i also just think
that it's covid
and they couldn't get an audience in so
it's a roast and
don't drink for every joke about dale
one thing you all don't know about dale
nothing
because he doesn't shut the [ __ ] up i'm
like bro there's one dolly and it's
dalai lama it ain't you
i've witnessed three cameramen collapse
after falling asleep
listening to you zing you look like the
boa constrictor from the jungle book and
it's only a matter of time before claire
snaps out of your spell
you've said that you're the best suited
for claire
do me a favor swing by my chateau for a
little lesson in fashion for the big day
you big diva don't drink for every time
claire
looked annoyed about it there's through
dale right like
take it take your time everyone that's
coming at him
i mean the jokes weren't that funny but
these men
also aren't comedians and then
wow wow wow claire says to the camera
as if she's talking to the men i like
dale
are you new here i like him
that's the whole point are you new here
no claire i'm actually not new here i've
been here the whole time
i know that you haven't talked to me and
that you don't know my name and you
barely recognize me actually i've gotten
very little camera time because you're
only talking a deal so no i'm not new
i've
consistently been here i waited for
months to get here and i've been in
quarantine and
gotten tested and gave up my life and
like my relationship with my family like
be here in isolation for you
what did you guys think of that comment
i found it to be
harsh i did uh the guys were told they
were on a date about roasting
and so they wrote their roasts and i
don't think they like got together to
make it all about dale i think that they
were just individually
trying to do the best they could on the
date and the dale jokes were there
on the one hand claire wants everything
to be about dale
and wants to be with dale all the time
uh on the other hand she's
upset when things are all about sale
that's one plus two plus one plus one
what do we think of dale at this point
because the other guys had gotten
frustrated with him this episode
but then dale and easy are talking and
it's an easy conversation and
i liked dale here he he he took the
shots from the roast he said look it was
deserved it's cool
i got scorched you got blurred i'll own
it i should
i rightfully so like after the other
night like
it was coming in it should have you know
so you know what cheers to dave
should i start it off with bennett i'd
love to talk to you awesome fantastic
cool
oh and we're back to bennett we're
getting a moment with bennett
just one moment with bennett
oh but it's gonna be about dale you went
for dale so hard
yes uh claire pulls bennett aside and
he's like
can we not talk about damn i gave dale
enough air time
you know during the roast i'd love to
kind of finish that conversation and
move on you know
and she's like yeah dale
yeah what was the conversation that he
was saying
that he was thinking he's the best
suited for me it did seem to me that she
was using
those chats to find out more about
dale's feelings for her
than about the men at all she was
justifying it by saying that she needed
to find out what was going on in the
house i'd like to know what goes on in
the house
if i need to know you probably already
got the gist of it but there was no
mystery to be solved here to me like i
can't be doing that
you know like it doesn't feel right and
oh
my god
in another breaking the fourth wall
moment clear seems to be talking about
the roast
and she says of the guys you dished
on my fiance so
hard i really don't think i could sit
there and go you've dished on my fiance
so hard
my fiance fiance
i'm not frozen on a zoom i'm here our
connection's still good
and the connection between claire and
dale is apparently
an engagement you've dished on my fiance
so
hard to get engaged
why is she calling you refusing
oh i'm in a dale spin
what did you think of claire calling
dale her fiance
in episode three let me know in the
comments
i love this show this is such a good
season the gift that keeps on giving
right
and after this group dale uh claire
doesn't give
any of the guys a rose
oh yeah i actually did not get what i
needed with you guys
right now i feel like this rose um i
won't be able to give this out tonight
i'm not sure if this has ever happened
in franchise history is it another
franchise first historians i implore you
let me know in the comments below but
claire does give
herself the rose claire thank you for
showing up tonight
i just want to let you know that
i'm so proud of you for being bold
saying how you feel speaking up living
your truth
and showing up for me you tonight
deserve this rose so wow wow
wow what an episode everybody you know
we get the teaser and
it's kind of the stuff we've seen before
it's the other guy's saying what are we
going to do
about me claire's gone and we kind of
see a little bit more of claire in tears
i've just blown up the bachelorette
and then oh my
god
[Music]
oh my gosh they just threw it in there
at the end
her coming out of the pool looking
gorgeous
her emerging no words no explanation
just time just screen time and she is
coming out of that pool right on time
because we need this
everybody what did you think of that
reveal
we are going to get tasha's bachelorette
please let me know your thoughts in the
comments below as always i love you guys
so much i'm so happy to be back here
with you talking about all this
insane stuff and just escaping and
enjoying ourselves i am available on
cameo if you want a personal message
from me
i also live tweet the show every week on
twitter i'm on instagram and tick tock
and it is halloween so hope everybody
has a great halloween
[Music]
no everybody helps you have a good
halloween too
the ghost is here she's been here the
whole time
yeah you think
you're excited about tasha she is
i love you guys thank you so much bye
[Music]
babes hi i'm drinking coffee and i had
to vlog what an episode i forgot to say
next week because of a different drama
the election
the bachelorette will be airing on
thursday thursday november 5th for one
week only so roses and rose will be up
on friday and also shameless plug i
talked to chris harrison about
all the drama that it happened and that
has to happen still
including the chatter that claire was
allegedly forced out
of the season that interview was up at
[Music]
etnline.com
[Music]